I am a professional Chocobo breeder
what is Final Fantasy VII that is
that's an enormous question fun Fantasy
7 is a beloved RPG that was released by
Square Enix back in 1997. an epic
adventure to save the planet it was a
cultural Landmark it was the first game
that really opened my eyes to the
role-playing genre it's a video game
that changed the life of many many many
people I like jrpg's before Final
Fantasy 7 but then after that was like
jrpgs were the thing it was the first
which had these like 3D little chunky
characters and it had cut scenes which
at the time were the most incredible
Graphics you know you'd ever seen I
couldn't believe what I was seeing when
I when I was watching first this was
like
I'm looking at the future
[Music]
first memory of Final Fantasy VII was
going over to my cousin's house and
seeing him fight Ultimate Weapon and
chasing him around the sky
and then he bumped into Ultimate Weapon
which started like the you know the
random battle the turn-based battle and
I'd never seen a turn-based battle
before and my first reaction was this
was this is really really stupid this
was way before I was ever into RPGs or
enjoyed jrpgs or anything I thought they
were for nerds but I remember being
really confused you're taking turns
smacking each other they were just they
were just standing there I I didn't like
I as a child I didn't understand what I
was looking at wait a minute I'm just
like waiting for the guy to shoot me
realistically as a kid I was kind of
like I wish I could just run up and hit
them
I was playing Killer Instinct and Street
Fighter and all these other fighting
games however uh so as soon as I saw
like a summon I was like this looks
really crazy this looks a lot different
than jrpgs that I'm used to which are
usually like Lord of the Rings dnd-esque
Knights and battlefields and all that
kind of stuff and here we are in this
modern setting
um with swords but also guns it looked
different from other Final Fantasy games
that I had played and I was immediately
drawn in this was different it was
cyberpunk it looked had a it had a
different visual appeal than most of
those other games like this game's
really I need to get I need to get a
copy of this game
foreign
[Music]
the opening cut scene of Final Fantasy
VII is probably one of the best intros
ever I couldn't believe that they would
hold on this shot of stars for so long
that they would hang on these shots and
have this music and establish this
atmosphere and hearing the music and
seeing the lighting and aerith's face
and the cutscene and the in in the
opening cutscene with the maku going
everywhere it starts with the kind of
mid-call reveal and it's a very somber
almost kind of like contemplative moment
it establishes this whole thing where
you're in this gigantic City but you're
like one small part of it and Shinra
feels so massive and imposing it lowers
down you see the scums of midgar you see
aerith and then all of a sudden it's
like
it just grouted by the collar and just
yanked me through that screen I remember
feeling so
pumped when I saw Cloud just flip off
that train it just gets you pumped like
it's such a good opening cut scene
Buckle me in like I do this to say like
I'm getting on the roller coaster bring
down the roller coaster Buckle me in
let's go you realize that oh this is
we're getting off to a running start
with this game
midgar kind of felt like the end of the
game almost to me at that age you fell
off in an enclosed location like Final
Fantasy every Final Fantasy does this
eventually you're let out into the these
wide world that you can experience when
I first left midgar uh I thought the
game was over you kind of see oh there's
all these sectors you're seeing all this
poverty you're seeing all these
different areas that means the whole
game is going to take place in midgar
that in itself felt like a massive world
and that took all this time and now
there's this there's this massive world
and what does it have for me ready to go
it felt like walking outside after being
cooped up for weeks or something like
that oh we're outside of midgar and this
is only disc one I felt like I was on a
road trip with my buddies I'll never
forget it that's like a mind-blowing
moment that should be on like the back
of the box but the fact that it wasn't
spoiled for me is is insanely cool
[Music]
thank you
so sephiroth killing aerith uh is easily
one of the most impactful moments in
like video game history if you look at
that cutscene of Eris dying
the direction of that cutscene is still
so beautiful and so masterful and it's
so it's so cruel the way that it's done
by the devs so geniusly like sephiroth
like coming down with the big sword it
is
horrific it's how she died that I think
is the what made me feel the most sad
because it's almost like it was too
violent it's the claim where characters
will die and then you know this just use
a phoenix down like you know they you
know they actually die but she for real
just sunk to the bottom died dead gone
goodbye six feet under and uh I'm pretty
sure I cried as a kid I was so
heartbroken I was so sad I was like ah
she's not gonna die they're not gonna
kill her the rest of the game is gonna
be about getting her back I get it or
we're gonna have to get her back in some
way and you just can't you just have to
live with that this this message about
life and death and the acceptance of the
fact that we will lose important people
there's really no one else like Eric her
limit breaks for example that that heal
everyone you you can't really feel that
slot with her because of that there's no
replacing her and I feel like that
emulates the Sensation that you get when
you actually lose somebody you had this
beam of light in front of you the whole
game and then
with one motion she's gone most people
are if you're a normal human being
you're devastated by that moment right
like you're a character has been killed
yeah
just didn't care very much I don't think
there was any real great Association
emotionally for me if anything I think
the reason that is the case is because I
didn't like using her as her character
from a gameplay perspective I was kind
of like oh well you know it doesn't
really affect me that much losing aerith
in that moment so like as a teenage boy
was not as impactful because I didn't go
on a date with her look she was one of
my party members so I cared because she
was one of my party members but like I
kind of knew it was gonna happen and it
wasn't Tifa the date I ended up for some
reason I think going on with Tifa uh so
I didn't get like a lot of that
connection which normally happens on a
lot of people's first playthrough if it
was Tifa I would have been pissed I
would have stopped playing the game but
it wasn't so you know what it was all
good that makes me a bad person but
maybe you should rethink some of your uh
your stances
foreign
[Applause]
yes hang out at the Gold saucer yes I
did everything at Gold sauce for that
area really wins you over with how
quirky and weird it is it had a Vibe you
know it had a Cool vibe some of my
favorite backgrounds in that game are
gold saucer I love the Haunted Mansion
why it's so weird and spooky I tried to
do every single thing possible I was
that weird guy that figured out that
cloud could go on dates with everyone
including Barrett definitely as a
teenage boy caused a lot of schoolyard
conversations of like dude you go on a
date with oh I went on a date with Baron
I don't know what's going on like you go
there and it's just like Hey we're
having fun it's the gold saucer that
theme is forever burned into my head
actually has like retinal burn OLED burn
into my eyes and my ears and my brain I
can see the music
forever and ever and ever I played many
many games I got really really good at
that little basketball mini game the
mini game that I was most fixated on was
the bike mini game and I don't even
think they had different tracks in fact
it was just the same track that you do
when you leave midgar
hey I'm gonna play the motorcycle mini
game again because it's amazing and just
played over and over and over again go
and hang out and play the snowboard mini
game which I think I actually liked a
little bit more definitely the
snowboarding game the snowboarding was
my personal fave
personally I the roller coaster is one
of my personal favorites I didn't even
know that was there uh for maybe like
until my third or fourth playthrough of
it of course the battle arena the battle
arena I think is actually like kind of a
roguelike before roguelikes or Rogue
light was was ever even you know a thing
man oh man those slot machines will
forever be ingrained in my mind just
that the noise they make and the in the
colors ugh it's so good ff7 is a unique
game because it has a lot of mini games
in it it inspired me I used to make
video games on RPG Maker when I was in
high school and I would literally make
gold saucer-esque areas in RPG Maker for
my big RPGs that were just mini game
zones
I think I did some of the racing and
stuff like that when you would do those
races you would see oh look at all these
cool prizes you can win look at all
these people you can race against and
you felt good racing them but there was
that one guy who had the black Chocobo
and he had his hat and he always beats
you no matter what and I knew in my
mind's eye that that guy had to go down
I had to figure it out I know the ins
and outs of how to take basic choco bows
that have certain certain elements that
can then breed together with a certain
nut to then evolve into a green Chocobo
a blue Chocobo a red Chocobo then you
have to like if you want a blue versus a
green and male versus female you gotta
like reload to get us a black Chocobo
eventually to get the golden Chocobo the
Chocobo breeding is such a nightmare and
then finally when you breed it properly
you know you're like I got it I got it I
got the gold chocobo oh this is so
exciting to be able to explore the game
and do everything and then get Knights
of the Round and Knights of the Round
even though it's literally over a minute
long
[Music]
the first time I used Knights of the
Round I was laughing like a hyena the
entire time it was so funny to sit there
back in the day it was so cool just
seeing these like minute long summons at
the time it was like I didn't want I
just wanted to watch it in its Majesty
every time Knights of the Round when you
first see it is really incredible
but when you have to see it the 20th
time and the animation is
so long
um it does get on your nerves a little
bit wow this is really long
that was the time you knew all right I'm
gonna go to the bathroom I'm gonna get
something to eat uh I'm gonna call a
friend uh cause you were plugged in this
was a cut scene that was playing for all
for a long time all those old you know
Final Fantasy summon animations are way
too long and I don't think they made
them skippable and and I was the kid
that was like all right I did it once if
I do W summon I can do it twice and then
I can make my whole party mimic so no
matter what it was Knights of the Round
all day nice to the round nice round is
one of the sickest Summons of all time
oh it's a bunch of dudes hitting them
with swords okay
[Music]
love fighting the Ruby weapon the Ruby
weapon is this boss that is is so
difficult to fight so difficult to parse
down it's one character versus this
gigantic weapon with these tentacle
things attacking from behind and you
have to just come up with the most
intricate battle chest like game plan to
take down the Ruby weapon I definitely
discovered the weapons Emerald weapon
the one underwater I remember first
seeing that and it just comes out it's
just like nah I don't know about this
you know like turning and running away
from it not letting it get you anytime
you go down it could be like right up
here like right next to you he is so
memorable to me because of how many
times I tried to beat him one of my
personal favorites is the safe boss from
the midgar Mansion you know the guy with
the half face I think what I love about
the safe boss is that you can fight him
from very early on in the game and if
you want to fight him super early he's
one of the most difficult fights the
final battle against therefore off
you see clouds against sephiroth like
1v1
the cutaways between the two of them and
it's just like pitch black darkness you
versus him it was like nothing I'd ever
experienced at that point you have to
hit this low before like you hit this
low as a player as Cloud Strife feeling
like all hope is absolutely lost and the
the evil if you will is so
insurmountable that there's no possible
way that you'll be able to overcome it
you feel the emotion and anguish in that
limit bar there's nothing more
satisfying than seeing that limit bar
just fill up and Cloud just goes Omni
Slash
foreign
it's another moment where it's it's as
beautiful as it is like an action-packed
moment
finally Cloud gets his revenge so then
when you finally do
a new avenge
I save the planet
um it feels really good the final moment
in that game is something that really
sticks with you
the final fight was sephiroth and the
crater when the music kicks in when
there's like vocals going on for one
inning Angel insane but a friend of mine
was like do you want to go to the final
time to see remake concert we went to
the Final Fantasy VII concert the Royal
Albert Hall thank you very much and it
was incredible and it finished on
sephiroth
[Music]
and then all of a sudden the choir comes
in and it's like
there is just something about One Winged
Angel that is so unsettling and just so
beautifully orchestrated right this is
kind of like where the entire jrpg Trope
of like the big Latin choir like really
started and when you're facing off
against sephiroth it really feels like
oh my God I'm going up against this
Godly being that I don't know if I have
a chance against
I think my favorite track in all of
Final Fantasy 7. it's not the obvious
one everyone's gonna say you know sepha
Roth sephiro's theme but it's the it's
kind of the Preamble before it
banana
it's like the boogeyman's coming to get
you
my favorite piece of music from Final
Fantasy 7 is Judgment Day
it's not demon Gloom like you'd expect
when you're going into the final dungeon
You're Going deeper and deeper into the
crater and I really like the umatsu
Incorporated small parts of aerith's
theme there was such a unique tone to
Final Fantasy VII that was largely
established by the music the Shinra
theme
it's this Sinister corporate music like
it feels like this Corporation just
taking over everything it sounds like
the planet dying you know and it's
really beautiful Bears theme
[Music]
underneath the rotting Pizza I think it
was and it's that bass line
[Music]
the Fanfare every time every time you
get a win
no I'm not a musical person I'm not even
gonna try it's gonna be so bad they
played it at the Olympics
[Music]
oh fantasy Victory music and I lost my
mind
tifa's theme just because I I it's just
so pretty
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
my favorite character when push comes to
shove has to be Tifa Lockhart I
identified with her a lot as a kid
um and I had hoped to you know grow up
and kick as much butt as she does plus
she has long dark hair I've always had
long dark hair it just made sense but
she's just as powerful for the most part
as cloud Who wields a giant sword and
she's just using her fists I think it it
also started my love affair with girls
who could kick the [ __ ] out of me and
Tifa is definitely falls into that
category she's amazing
um she you know she literally like you
know uses her fists to [ __ ] people up
um you know she's running the bar she's
so intelligent
um she's got the whole unreal quite love
thing going on respect he for Lockhart
because she is Queen it's actually such
a strong cast of characters that I I
find it hard to pick one oh my favorite
character it's got to be said it's got
to be said uh I love a sid I just love
him that big old grin of his he's got
the Airship I always go for the
characters that are effortlessly cool
cloud is a try hard cool which is fine
um but like Sid is not trying to be cool
it's just cool everyone always says that
cloud is a Punky ass
they always say that cloud is an emo kid
they always say that he's the worst
character in the game he's a blank slate
no one knows what he's doing
but all you gotta do is recognize that
Zach fair is actually the true version
of cloud Zach fair for those of you who
don't know is the character that
essentially Cloud spoiler alert lies
pretends to be if you know what happens
to him in the game he's not just an emo
dude that a lot of people remember him
from like Advent Children I love the his
character Arc throughout this game to
what was the the end of the game when
Tifa helps him to kind of recomplete his
mind and bring it all back together you
see how much the cloud had grown as a
person but that acceptance eventually of
of of who and what he really is that he
never made it into soldier that he's not
a tough guy that reveal that happens
through that whole sequence that whole
life life stream sequence between
tiefling cloud is just really great so
to the eventual helmet pull off and all
this stuff like what is going on wait he
was that guy like I I'll never forget
that moment specifically it's probably
my favorite in the whole game that
moment of sort of vindication for that
character
um where it was right under your nose
the breadcrumbs had been there the whole
time it really felt like uh a magician's
trick or something like that it was so
masterfully crafted he's portrayed as
this person who's really you know sad
and you know kind of emotional in a
negative sense by the end of the game
he's actually quite optimistic as a
person Mr jrpg himself I'd argue there
has never been a better main protagonist
for a jrpg much less like a video game
that picture of cloud just the bus just
sort of his back pops in my head every
time
I feel like that's maybe the most iconic
weapon that sword has gotta be
six feet long by like you've got this
little skinny guy with this it's just
stupid like how big that sword is I just
loved seeing it wielded by a dude with
arms is the size of a toothpick one of
my lifelong dreams is I'll buy like a
good replica bus to sword at some point
I love crop replicas and I need to get
the proper replica of that sword I need
to because it'd be amazing somewhere
back here actually I actually have the
sword right here because I wanted it so
bad as a kid and I really do have it in
real life honestly it's one of the most
iconic video game weapons of all time
the legacy of Final Fantasy 7 it's kind
of hard to quantify I mean Jesus it's
the legacy of Final Fantasy VII is it
changed
everything it really opened a lot of
people's eyes to a whole genre of games
that were completely just we were
completely unaware of before it wasn't
until Final Fantasy 7 that all of a
sudden Western producers and developers
were like wait
this can sell in the west and all of the
sudden we started getting all these
amazing jrpgs Final Fantasy 7 made
jrpg's mainstream I felt like when ff7
came out it took over the world a jrpg
being the second highest selling game on
the PlayStation that that's insane
taking video games seriously
picking video game music seriously
and taking the themes of what video
games can teach us seriously it's not
action scenes it's not explosions it's
emotion I think it's easy to
forget how important of a game it is
because everyone is constantly saying
that it's an important game it becomes
White Noise yes of course it's important
everyone keeps saying it's important but
it is truly truly like a landmark moment
in video game history it allowed a
developers and creators and kids who are
playing it with kind of a creative bone
in their body to dream massively I just
think of it and I get so happy it exists
and so thankful to the people who made
it because it has just brought me such
tremendous joy and I am only one person
so many people still feel that way
everyone having similar experiences to
that so many other people that describe
a similar thing to me like even like
Robert Pattinson
um is really heartwarming to know that
oh it wasn't just me Final Fantasy 7 has
had a an immeasurable impact on me when
I played Final Fantasy 7 and like fell
in love with those characters that cost
and went on the journey with them I knew
that was one of them moments where like
I said previously like I understood the
impact that games could have on people
because I could feel it happening to me
honestly I think more so than anything
else in my life jrpg protagonists had
been the ones who influenced who I am as
a person those were the ones I always
seem to latch onto and want to be like
that whole Persona was kind of who I
wanted to be I'm pretty sure Final
Fantasy 7 was my personality for a while
it was very much a safe haven for me I
think that like my taste in media in
general was deeply influenced by me
first playing Final Fantasy VII Final
Fantasy VII taught me how to invest in
characters at the very young age now
I've come to so love kind of those those
stories a la Kingdom Hearts Allah Final
Fantasy
um where they just seem so convoluted
and complex but the stakes are so high
it was the first time
I really thought about a lot of these
things because I was a 12 year old kid
at the time
so thinking about climate change and
things like that which are which are a
result directly of our consumerism
thinking about you know corporate greed
I didn't think about
those things at all before playing Final
Fantasy VII I hope that the people that
worked on that game you know when it
comes time for them I hope that they
they know that they in their lifetime
they made something profound that
changed the world I don't understand
morbid here but I know I'm gonna be
Final Fantasy VII a bunch of times
between now and when I die as that
thought makes me really happy
so in the battle between aerys or aerith
I think I gotta go aerith to me
it's always been heiress sometimes I
like to be called Trisha and sometimes I
like to be called Trish
either is fine whichever you choose